[Music]
the witcher 3 has
dozens of haunting and disturbing
monsters but you might not know that the
inspiration for many of them
lie in some really strange gnarly
folklore
diving into mythology and seeing what
exactly medieval europeans were most
afraid of can really shed light on what
makes the fantastical creatures of the
witcher
so haunting haunting at least when
you're not totally distracted with side
quests
lost your key ma'am no not me k
me pan playing gwent and talking to pigs
all right let's talk
there may be minor spoilers for in-game
quests ahead but let's dive right in and
start the story
botchlings these grotesque zombies are
the tragic result of an improperly
buried child after it has died
hunting pregnant women at night the
botchling drains the mother of her
strength before brutally killing both
her
and the fetus you might think it'd be no
problem for the white wolf to defeat an
evil ghost baby but if a giant frog
proved to be a tough opponent
you may want to reconsider attacking the
botchling in the family matters main
quest
when threatened the footlong botchling
can change form growing into a deformed
powerful man botchlings are based
partially on
milings the ghosts of discarded or
unbaptized
infants in scandinavian folklore mylinks
were said to have roamed the land and
jumped on the backs of lone travelers
demanding to be taken to a graveyard and
buried properly
but as the traveler neared a graveyard
the myling became heavier and heavier
and more difficult to carry
and if the traveler couldn't make it
before the myling's patience was up it
would ragefully kill them
similar creatures that also inspired the
botchlings were the slavic pyronic and
drokovic
which were deceased children or infants
that similarly turned into hostile
demons when abandoned
however if it was given a proper burial
at the family home
instead of becoming wandering demons
they would become a protective house
spirit much like how if botchlings are
given a proper name through an elven
naming ritual their curse can be lifted
turning them into a docile spirit called
a lubricant
it's generally assumed these folktales
about vengeful myelins and peronic exist
to discourage people from committing the
sadly common middle-aged
practices of child abandonment and
infanticide
even hansel and gretel is about the
dangers that children face out on their
own
i definitely say that the in-game
origins of botchlings and the folklore
they're based in
are equally tragic and unsettling noon
wraiths
when the sun reached its highest point
in the sky on a hot summer day
farmers on the brink of exhaustion were
said to have visions of dancing maidens
that drew them in
and killed them that's dance encountered
in the contract quest
devil by the well and the white lady the
inspiration for noon wraiths directly
lie in slavic folklore
known in poland as poludnica meaning
lady midday
this mythological creature takes the
form of whirling clouds of dust and
carries a scythe and shears
on hot days in rural fields the spirit
attempts to start conversations with
delirious field workers and farmers
but if anyone fails to answer her or
tries to change the subject
she'll decapitate them with her scythe
or strike them with a heart attack
these haunting creatures are now widely
believed to basically be the
personification of heat stroke that
field laborers risk suffering
symptoms of heat stroke include
hallucinations and seeing or hearing
imaginary people
so that makes sense however this fear of
lady midday somewhat led to the practice
of taking breaks during the day to avoid
her wrath and
avoid exhaustion but geralt sure doesn't
seem to have a problem with facing noon
wraiths
visually similar to noon rates and
similar to fight plague maidens in the
witcher 3
are spirits that personify disease and
pestilence
annabelle encountered in the quest a
tower full of mice is a spirit revealed
to be a plague maiden after she was
eaten alive by
rats being rendered defenseless by a
paralyzing potion during a riot
that is a rough demise in the witcher
the catriona plague also known as the
red
death swept through the northern
kingdoms much like the bubonic plague
did in europe
the bestiary describes catriona diseased
patients is having
visions of a decrepit ghost resembling
an old woman
covered in scabs and boils as stated
eloquently in the witcher 3 art book
her rotten worm-ridden flesh is covered
in a ragged shroud seemingly woven from
miasma and foul
vapors crawling out from under it are
dozens of plague-bearing rats
yikes that's some very specific language
i feel like i can smell the plague
maiden from here
plague maidens are closely inspired by
the scandinavian spirit
pesta the physical embodiment of the
bubonic plague
the word pesta or pest is literally
norwegian for plague
the spirit of pesto was an old woman
dressed in black
that wiped out entire populations with
illness including a third of denmark's
population
and nearly half of norway's in just four
years during the 14th century
pesta traveled from village to town
bringing and spreading the black plague
with her
it was said that if you saw her carrying
a rake you'd know she'd only take a few
lives but if you saw her sweeping with
her broomstick
there would be mass fatalities of the
many creatures in the witcher universe
the noon wraiths and plague maidens are
some of the most loyal to their folklore
and some of the most creepy
if you've played the witcher you know
there's a bit of nudity so be warned for
the next section
alps who could forget the screeching
blood covered vampires from the blood
and wine expansion that creep around on
the tips of their toes
alps are based in germanic folklore and
are actually similar to elves
at least the more traditional morbid
idea of elves
alps in the witcher and alps in folklore
are both gray-skinned shape-shifters
with pointy ears but they're typically
male
while their female counterparts are
called mare or mara
similar to their in-game abilities
middle-aged folklore describes alps
seeking out sleeping targets in the
night and twisting their dreams into
horrific nightmares
in fact even the german word for
nightmare alpdrum
literally means elf dream alps perch on
the chest of their sleeping victims and
become heavier and heavier until the
victim wakes up being crushed
unable to move or breathe under the alps
weight
interestingly enough these attacks from
creatures across different cultures are
so prevalent
it's now believed that these were early
explanations for sleep paralysis
which is when a person wakes up feeling
totally unable to move or breathe
as well as possibly sleep apnea night
tears or lucid dreams
but alps also happen to like pulling
pranks like magically making milk turn
sour or
tangling people's hair into elf knots or
putting babies back into soiled
diapers wait what crushing farm animals
to death
and even drinking blood from the nipples
of men and young children
yeah okay maybe it's best that the alps
in the witcher don't stick completely to
their folklore but they are definitely
still creepy in their own
way the witcher 3 has a complex world
that aims for both fantasy
and realism a senior environment artist
on the game jonas matson even said
we don't rely on the classic fantasy
tropes when we create our world
we create it based off how people used
to live and what they used to believe
some of the truly horrifying qualities
of the game's monsters may be
as horrifying as they are because
they're based on real fears and real
human experiences
hopefully no one actually had a vampire
elf on their chest giving them
nightmares but
you never know either way the witcher 3
without a doubt has some seriously
creepy
quirky and unforgettable enemies
[Music]
you